all right here we go
hello everybody
hope everybody is doing
well
and so before we start the q a a few
announcements um
there will be a conference by the way
with myself john viveki paul vander clay
um and
i forget the name of the other person dr
richard mondral which will be on
the
from september 15 to september 18th and
it actually starts a few days earlier
for those who want to arrive early we're
going to uh to it's going to be called
consciousness and conscience and it's in
thunder bay ontario you can look that up
on
eventzilla.net and you'll find the
details for that it's going to be a lot
of fun
it's going to be there's even going to
be
an airsoft game with barbecue and it's
going to be a lot of it is going to be
about spending time together and seeing
each other in the flesh and
discussing ideas you know and getting to
know each other so i'm definitely
looking forward to that i haven't met
paul vander clay in person yet and so
that'll be really wonderful looking
forward to that so check that out for
those who could come it would be great
to meet you there
um
and so here we go with the questions for
those who know these question uh the
people who support me on patreon or on
my website for 10 or more get to ask
questions in advance and then i will
answer they get sorted and sifted
you know down um especially if the
questions that i've already asked or
that people have already asked are
unclear are removed and then those and
then about around 50 questions remain i
answer those and then people who anybody
who supports me in any way or is on the
facebook group uh is
it will get the link so they are in the
the chat if they want to and so i also
interact with the chat and so that's how
this works and then we publish them
uh publicly so if you want to cut you
want to show up there are ways to access
it through the facebook group um
and so yeah all right so here we go so
i'm going to start
with the website
all right and so
wall she asks you previously spoke about
the symbolism of naming after something
and gave the examples of cities and
children how does naming something like
an album or a comic god's dog for
example different from naming a child or
city particularly when assets of humor
come into play
um
and so i i mean there isn't a difference
it's just a difference of level you know
you name a book or you name something in
relationship to something it's just
referring to that
to to that saint or to to the the person
you are naming it after
and so in a way it
it refers to them it uses them as an
anchor and so
there i don't think there's necessarily
a difference when humor comes into play
you know of course if you're going to
use humor you have to be careful the way
that you use it because you know you
don't want to
um
you don't you don't you don't want to
make
humorous you don't want to be humorous
about something that's not funny i mean
that's the only thing i can say about
that uh
so
yeah
um and so eric
asks how jonathan in acts 16 16 30 we
see paul after losing his patience
invoke the name of christ to drive a
spirit out of a slave girl this actually
leads to him and silas being stripped
and beaten with rods and put into the
deepest part of the prison
at night they pray and sing him to the
lord an earthquake shakes the prison the
doors open the chains loose him it seems
this might to me the smearing of christ
going down into hades also paul also
that paul gets punished for losing his
patience thoughts on this christ is
risen
uh and so
i mean it's it it is i think i think
it's definitely supposed to manifest to
some kind of small version of the
resurrection in general you know when
they when someone goes down into prison
and then comes out of prison
it's usually an image of resurrection
you see that in the story of uh
of joseph
um
and so yeah that's that's definitely
what it is
i mean it is a really interesting story
like it's a super interesting story the
way that it's presented you know the
idea that that paul that saint paul
loses
is annoyed with this with this lady and
so because of that he chases out the
demon it's just kind of funny it is a
kind of a funny story when you think
about it you know because why didn't he
it's like it feels in the story that
he's not doing it for her he's doing it
because it's a nuisance
uh so but i haven't really thought about
it so much so interesting um but i think
there is a deeper there is definitely in
in terms of he does free her because
she's also used kind of like as a slave
by the people that are that are uh using
her to finance their this operation like
that using her to get money from this
operation that they
that they have using her as a soothsayer
and so i think that they are definitely
freeing her from uh from slavery so
all right so in the chat ivan engel asks
is paradise meant to be built on earth
or is it an ever distant ideal how could
it manifest if not through power used by
authority and humility and subjected to
christ
and so i don't think that paradise is
meant to be built on earth i think that
there can be glimmers of it there can be
reflections of it but you always always
have to be careful
that
the way you act isn't trying to create
another tower of babel and so i think
there have been
so if you think of the man in which
constantinople it'd be what it became i
think that
there was a sense in which they wanted
to create a a holy city to the extent
that that's possible
but that city would also have a kind of
hierarchy in it um and would also
leave room for uh some chaos you know
they had so for example in in the
constantinople
they they uh banned the glade the
gladiator fighting but they they still
had chariot racing so they still had
sports and stuff like that in the form
of chariot racing so it was kind of like
a
a less extreme version of of of some of
the negative aspects like i'm sure there
was gambling and there was all that
stuff based on the the sporting events
and and there are moments like the nikka
revolt when that space like that space
of sport and of uh entertainment became
let's say the bubbling of a social
revolution
um but in a certain manner it's hard to
you don't want to just create a another
tower of babel so
so i think you have to be careful with
the building of heaven on earth so the
way you would build like you could say
something like the way you built heaven
on earth really is becoming a saint and
uh and then around you there'll be a
you know there's a chance in which
around you some type of heaven will
some type of you know paradise will
manifest itself around you you know
something like that
all right and so david flores asks with
all the current discussion on higher
level beings agregors angels and
principalities i was wondering if the
parable of the sower connects to these
ideas the bird eats the seeds on the
wayside
seeds are stolen by birds assuming birds
are analogous to higher level beings how
does this play out in reality or is this
connection and misunderstanding thanks
for the help
um
definitely like for sure we're having a
lot of discussions on that like there's
still i had another discussion with john
viveki and jordan hall which is going to
be coming out pretty soon maybe tomorrow
i'm thinking i'm not sure uh and then
there's also um another discussion that
i had with the two guys who wrote the
article on the symbolic world so there's
a lot of discussion on that and i think
your inside is quite right i think your
insight is right that it's related to
the manner in which
um
like the manner in which
let's say
intelligent patterns from heaven
how they can be embodied in the world
and so the i think you're probably right
that the birds that take the seed
take the seed
is something like
these parasitic
patterns of heaven you could say
you know these lower patterns but that
are still and they they they don't
they prevent the world from i also
talked about it like in terms of ideas
that don't uh fit with the world like
ideas that can't be they can't land and
so there's something about that as well
but there's your intuition is right it's
not exactly the same but it's definitely
related because it's talking about
the manner in which
higher principles exist in the world so
all right alejandro
uh
jurado says hey jonathan if you state
that higher level beings have an
influence over people and affect their
will how does this permit destroy the
vision of freedom to choose so
you always have to think about it
fractally it's not uh it's not
complicated you know because
let me ask you that question now uh
at a level that is not as
the problem is that when we think about
these higher beings i'm i'm really
excited to worry that people
are thinking about it too much in like a
woo like a magical way you know it
really just is the man in which things
exist so let me ask you this so
the fact that
your family
or your father
or your boss
or your mayor or your or the police or
any type of higher level being and
higher level authority the fact that his
that it has influence over you and
affects your will
does it permit and destroy the vision of
freedom to choose like and the answer is
no it doesn't it's like we have
freedom to choose within
higher systems and so we are bound by
our existence in higher systems and in
like bigger beings
but it doesn't at all
destroy your your freedom to choose
right you you
you exist within that and you choose
within that and if you transgress
especially to transgress the the
the body of your family then there will
be consequences of that if you
transgress
the the the city you live in then
there'll be consequences to that
but that's just how the world exists so
um
yeah and so that's the same like when i
talk about
higher level beings it's just it's just
the same so
let's say if you think that there are
intelligent patterns intelligent
watchers that are watching over natural
let's say patterns in the world in the
movement of the the the movement of the
sun and the stars in the sky
it's like does that destroy your your
your freedom to choose or permit the
freedom to jews it's like there's it
what it does it just like any type of
freedom it it gives the bounds to that
freedom and so
you know uh it's like
you're you know you
within that system you if you act
certain ways it will be damaging to you
and if you have act in other ways then
it'll be good to you
you know if you walk outside a duck in
in the darkness and you try to do the
same activities that you're doing during
the day then you're gonna pay the price
for that you know and if you
if you try to go outside you know in the
middle of july and try to sleep in the
sun then you'll you'll have a nice
surprise when you wake up with a nice
sunburn so it's like all these things
are
are just like
they're just the way we exist we that we
exist in the world we just have to
understand that there are intelligent
patterns that manage our our existence
and those are intelligible they're
intelligent and they and they have
causal effect they cause you
to exist in certain ways um but it's all
fractal so your
capacity to choose
uh is bound in that but it's not it's
it's neither
fully it's like it's it makes it
possible for you to choose within those
systems
um
because that makes sense
give me let me give you an example an
example that jordan peterson used once
which is that
um
it's like
systems of control or systems of
authority they give you the possibility
to choose
they don't remove it the idea that
higher beings manage
your
the way in which you live is is actually
gives you the possibility of choosing
like the example to to give you the
counter example would be it's like if i
drop you in the middle of the ocean and
i say all right you're totally free
right in the ocean you are totally free
you now you can do
whatever you want but there's nothing
in which to bound to bind your freedom
there's no order in which to bind your
freedom then like who cares like just
being in the middle or
dropping you in the middle of the the
the desert you know and it's like okay
you're free to choose like that doesn't
mean anything anymore so the idea is
that it this is actually what makes
freedom
real and possible um
so yeah
okay
all right so cormac jones uh
asked a question so by the way i want to
mention like cormac and a bunch of other
people i wrote a version of snow white
which i'm hoping to publish in the next
year or so i'm getting an illustrator to
do it and this is something that i want
to do which is to create um
to create some um
some fan fairy tales and kind of retail
fairy tales emphasizing the symbolism
but in a way that's not like that's not
tedious and explicit but rather kind of
brings out or teases out certain
symbolic strains uh and that are totally
fine to tell for kids but think that
adults would like as well
and so so cormac is one of the people
that read it and has given some
interesting critiques
about it so i'm happy about that
all right so good evening jonathan i
sometimes really like
something that i've made that's why i
made it right i created and saw that it
was good those two actions the creation
and the perception have been together
and can be hard to distinguish if i were
to write something say that to me
functions as the names of christ well i
would love that piece of writing because
i love christ and i love his image at
the same time i sinfully love myself
this image is something that i've made
it occurs to me that this is the
predicament of the iconographer and that
i should ask
one how it this works how does one make
an image of christ while worshiping
christ and his image and not worshiping
the works of one's hands
as would an idolater or someone captive
to self-love
um
and so i think
i think it's definitely a balancing act
you know um
i think that you can you you can notice
you could if you're attentive to the way
that other people react to what you've
you made you can probably
you could probably know whether or not
you're captive by self-love so for
example
if you feel like you're not getting
enough credit for what you've done
uh if you get angry if someone uh
if you automatically get angry if
someone cr criticizes what you've done
you know uh like i think it's fine to
defend what you've done and to explain
it and if people are misunderstanding it
but like if you if you have a reactive
like attitude to someone just because
they are giving you uh criticism
um
um and then also like can you part from
what you've done like are you attached
to it like you
for example like if you if you were
making some art you know would it hurt
you to get rid of it like would it would
you suffer from that
i think those are all little ways to
look it at that and figure out whether
or not you're kind of captive but it's
definitely uh
it's definitely a temptation you know i
i know cause like i have to deal with
that myself like you said it's like i
make icons i make these videos i make a
bunch of stuff i get excited about it
i'm happy about it and then it's like
you're right when when is it when is it
a little too much like when am i
just
just in a mode of like self promotion
and looking for attention it's like i'm
sure i fall into that all the time and
so god forgive me when i do i hope you
guys forgive me as well all right so a
popper
says
all right
so in the season of pride i have a
question about the meaning of lgbtq plus
this symbol represents the union of
people from sexual margin
the plus sign at the end represents all
the other sexual identities known or
unknown
what is the meaning of the cross
it represents the margin and the margin
being found at the end of this group of
identities
is there a hint of a possible acts 16 17
moment paul making explicit the unknown
god in athens where the unknown
cross will be made explicit at the end
of the carnival of pride um
i don't know i've never thought about it
that way i mean for sure
the way that that it's used in the lgbtq
plus
um
has to do i mean the funny thing about
it like it is kind of funny because
right in
in in hebrew i don't want to make sure i
want to make i think i'm right in hebrew
that's have tab is the last letter isn't
it
and so it's just interesting because the
tab is a cross
i was right yes so so in hebrew the last
letter is a is a tab and so it's
actually it's like a cross so it's
interesting that it's like the end it
really is the end
in this in this sense that it's related
to the end
um
and so that's kind of fascinating but i
think in their case what they want is to
say
it's it's like it's actually just a
it's an image of indefinite variability
it's like a plus it's like there are
many others but we haven't we're not
gonna make them explicit you know um so
that's my kind of understanding of it
um
so i see it more like that than the idea
of the unknown god it's more like the
end
and also the idea of the end as maybe a
dissolving into so many variables that
you can't name them it's just like chaos
basically
um and that had to do with death as well
like just a cross has to do with death
as well
so
maybe
interesting to think about that i'm sure
the tab thing people i've
sure the tab thing some people have have
uh
have been keen on that
someone which should check it up and see
if uh if people have come up with that
before
so ramal asked hi jonathan where's the
symbolism of surviving fire being
fireproof i've noticed the pattern in
christian stories such as the fiery
furnace and the martyrdom of santosh but
also in indian stories of testing
someone's purity by passing through fire
sita and pralada also does
that have some relation to joshua and
caleb passing through the desert and the
idea of fire in the last judgment and so
well for sure the idea in i think that
the idea
being fireproof
i mean
fire is a kind of death it's a kind of
death by multiplication or a death of
being consumed and so i think that
there are
many
more than one symbolism of that it could
have to do with what you're saying the
idea that i mean it could have to do
with the idea that
this person's integrity is beyond
the capacity to destroy right something
like that it could mean something like
that you try to destroy this person's
integrity
and uh you won't be able to like you
just won't be able to do it
there's also
there's also the image of be a burning
with fire without being consumed which
you see when in the um
of course in the uh
the burning bush and and that seems to
have something to do with theosis and i
think that that's something which has
been
represented in the idea of the the three
men in daniel too
um
that there's a notion of
resurrection of theosis
of
you know transformation
um all of that so but i've never thought
about it explicitly in that in those
terms so
you're definitely onto something
all right so simon
says
jonathan was the symbolism of jesus
spitting on the ground making mud and
applying it to the blind man's eyes to
heal him
is it to do with bringing heaven out of
jesus mouth to earth yes and where
heaven and earth meet there is wholeness
and healing
yeah i think that's what it is i think
you've got it it's definitely it's
definitely has to do with like
spit coming like with the water that
comes down
and then mixing
meeting the earth and then it becomes
like this unit of heaven and earth that
is healing the man i'm yeah i'm pretty
sure that's what it is so i think you've
got it exactly
um
all right so silcana
asks is paradise supposed to have no
chaos
and so
that's an interesting question
i think it has glory so
it's hard to think it's hard to totally
to think like does the do the lower
waters
like kind of continue to exist
i think so so it's not in paradise but
it's like paradise
paradise is is the hierarchy and on the
edge of that hierarchy is our is still
potentiality
you know and so you can imagine
so the idea would be that the work of
creation has to continue you see that
the idea of naming the animals and so
saint from the syrian for example says
that there are no animals in paradise
like the animals are outside of paradise
and so adam would like come down the
mountain to the border of paradise
basically the animals would come up to
him from outside from the chaos so it'd
be like these waters kind of coming out
of the sea you could it's not exactly
that but you can't imagine coming down
from below and then adam naming them and
so there's already there's always
potential more potentiality and more
chaos that can kind of be brought into
to
to order
um and so i think that that's the way to
understand paradise but for sure at the
end of time like when you look at the
image
of
the image of uh the the heavenly
jerusalem right it says
it says that there will be no more ocean
that is a crazy statement like that
statement i remember re it's like a year
or two ago
i was rereading revelation and i sent
that to my brother meter and he hadn't
read it in a while too and so he's like
what he really says there'll be no ocean
it's the end of time and so we're like
going into the text and like looking uh
and it it's pretty astounding uh so
yeah i don't even know what that means
like i don't even know i guess it means
that the fullness
this total fullness of god maybe but
it's scary to think the idea of like no
chaos like no potential wow
like the fullness of actuality i guess
that's what it is so
but there's also an image in revelation
of the sea becoming like glass which
isn't at the it's not at the at the
moment of the heavily jerusalem but it's
like maybe that's something like that
where
it's not chaos it's just like
still potentiality that completely
reflects you know the image from above
something like that
yeah
so choose agape as when the woman is
caught in adultery jesus writes with his
finger on the ground the ten
commandments were written by the finger
of the lord with the significance of the
finger thanks
so a finger fingers have to do with
pointing like that's the great genius of
the finger like a finger
points if finger
is
related to concentrating meaning
that pointing is is like you could
imagine like the
the most primordial form of language
that you can imagine is something like
pointing right so
it's like there's all this stuff and you
say that
this this thing that thing that is the
like the essence of
of language you could say the essence of
of naming is something like that right
um and so i think that that's why the
finger that's the significance of the
finger and that's why it's written by
the finger of the lord
um
yeah that's what it is it's like a
concentration into a point like that now
if you read matthew's book you'll you'll
get what that what that signifies like
that's the point you know that place
where things come together
so mary asked could you please comment
on the symbolism of the number 40 more
moses stays on mount sinai for 40 years
and 40 nights christ in the desert is
this somehow related to the human
gestation time of 40 weeks in the womb
and does it have anything to do with
birth or rebirth thank you and god bless
and so yeah there's also the 40 days of
rain
um
the 40 years in the desert
uh
that the hebrews the 40 days of rain for
the flood so it i mean it has to do with
a cycle for sure and the idea of 40
weeks the womb
definitely it has to do with a full
cycle
and so there are different there are
different like ways of representing the
full cycle in scripture sometimes it's
just seven right so seven days but then
sometimes it's 40
um
[Music]
i don't totally know whether 40 comes
from i struggle sometimes with like
i can see the numerical patterns but i'm
not the best at mathematical symbolism
so sometimes i see it like it's there
but i someone asked me like why is it 40
rather than 30 it's like i don't know
i don't know seven is easier you know
the first ten digits are easier but then
it becomes 12 maybe up to 12 is is
possible but
after that it gets hard to really
understand like why 40.
so sorry if i'm disappointing you
there all right so c street soul says
does the story of the apostle peter give
us any symbolic insight into the roman
catholic church and the role it plays in
broader christianity particularly saint
paul correcting said peter at antioch
when juxtaposed to pep people
infallibility or the apostle peter cut
also peter cutting the ear off a man
coming through as jesus when juxtaposed
to roman catholic church's crusades
and so my answer to that is i believe so
i really believe that
that uh the way that the story of christ
played out let's say in scripture
that it is also
to a certain extent playing out in the
bigger
as a cosmic version in the causing
version of christianity and so i think
that
all the qualities of the apostle peter
are there
and all the negative aspects of the
apostle peter are there it's like the
apostle peter
was the the you know the first of the
apostles he was the one
who christ said on this rock i will
build my church and then turn and then
you know write the next verse says get
behind me satan
so the apostle peter is the one that
walks out on the water and then he's the
one that sinks the apostle peter right
is the one that says i'll follow you
until i die
and then he denies christ at the cross
and so i think that
i think that that is a very mysterious
aspect
of peter and
and i think that it's going to play out
in the cosmic sphere now i want to be
careful
because i want you to understand that i
think that the apostle peter is still
the apostle peter
that even when the apostle peter is
sinking and even when the apostle peter
is denying christ he is still the one
that christ chose
and so
i don't and so although i i'm orthodox
i'm very careful i don't i don't want to
uh
i think that in the big story it's all
going to play out
and it's all going to play out in a way
that you know that ends with with christ
saying to the apostle peter
you know love
my sheep you know if you do you love me
and if you do then care for my sheep you
know
so so i want to be i want to be careful
that i do believe that it's playing out
in a car in a bigger sphere but i i
don't
it doesn't it i don't think it gives us
permission to make simplistic
interpretations about that
that it is it's a it's a it's a large
and complex story that is playing out so
um
so yeah and i think the same with saint
paul i think that there are
there are churches that revere saint
paul particularly
and those churches they have the
qualities of saint paul
you know um
especially in the west the idea of saint
peter and saint paul together was really
really
important in terms of a pattern and so i
often feel like the reformation is
something like the separation of saint
peter and st paul
and that
the reformation took on
saint paul
as
in in all his qualities but also all his
faults
um
and so yeah so it's definitely things to
think about if you want to think about
something
it's an interesting it's an interesting
idea
all right
all right so lisa says
can you comment on the carnivore diet
people go on it seem to to become almost
super human health-wise curing chronic
issues losing weight and not being a
slave to craving anymore but it comes at
a great cost lack of dietary resilience
and social exclusion technically they
can't even have the eucharist which is
the ultimate symbol of communion does
this has something to do with cane
and is there also a kind of inversion at
play eating meat comes from the fall and
kane founded cities but our current
culture
the end result of that is very anti-meat
and is the reason people are having
these chronic health issues in the first
place so i haven't figured it out man i
like lisa i haven't figured out this
carnivore thing
it is so mysterious that it's happening
that it's all it's happening now you
know and you're right it's like i i you
know i'm you know i'm looking watching
jordan peterson
and i'm kind of waiting i'm like it's
been five years really five years you
only eat meat salt and drink water
and uh you know he's definitely in a
better shape than i am
he's definitely like i'm kind of nice
and soft like getting nice and soft
around the edges you know i don't have i
get tired in the afternoon i don't have
that much energy and it's like
so i don't know man i've been wanting
i've been wanting to i've been telling
myself i'm going to try it at some point
you know just for a few weeks and see
what it does because i now i have so i'm
the people some guy in my parish
a guy a catechumen at
our parish you know i met him six months
ago and maybe a little more he was
walking with a cane
chronic
constant illness he he would go up the
stairs of his apartment and he would
have to lay down on the floor for 20
minutes because he could barely like
function
and
he went on the carnivore diet
and
like what is it a few weeks later he a
few months like a month later i don't
even know not very long afterwards no
more cane
no more constant pain
like i couldn't believe it he said like
this is something he's been dealing with
his whole life and so it's pretty
impressive so i don't know like i don't
even know i don't i don't know like i
don't know what to think i don't know it
has something to do with like the place
we are in the world like i mean does it
how could it have something to do with
kane like kane's a got an
agriculturalist like
i don't know i don't know what it is
it's it's interesting
yeah i'm still thinking about it so
i'll let you know if i come to
conclusions
so tony rosa says
in the recent rebel wisdom conversation
with john raviki and in the context of
the hermeneutics of beauty versus
suspicion discussion
john described beauty
beauty as a disclosure of reality it's
such a beauty and overlapping category
to symbol and if so what are the
distinctions or is it in fact equal to
the idea of symbol as i understand a
symbol a disclosure revelation a reality
of bringing together of epiphany of what
is in a sign
yes i told yes that's
exactly what it is that's exactly at
least the way that i see symbol that is
it's the gathering of the elements
together and to manifest its identity
and so and so when you can see the
symbol you can kind of see
you can see uh
reality like you're it's not hiding it's
not
masking reality
and so i totally agree
and it's interesting because it so so
it's interesting because you can see how
people who engage in only this type of
hermeneutics of suspicion
how they can sometimes engage in very
deep conspiracism because they have a
sense that symbols are always there
because symbols can't hide things it's
possible
symbols can be like secret languages
right that exists in the world where
only an in-group knows what the symbol
refers to and then the out-group doesn't
and so i'm not saying that that's not
possible that that can exist but there's
a way in which
for people who really get into kind of
conspiracism
like at a really deep deep deep level
they they start to think that all
symbolism is like that and all symbolism
is actually hiding some nefarious thing
behind it
uh and so you can see how it's it's kind
of brought
it's it's filled up every it filled up
different types of people's minds so
much
um
all right so
all right so now we're moving on to
patreon
so christian
so brandon burns sorry in the chat says
could you convince matthew to write a
bible companion
i don't think so i think
i think that's your
meteor like he has his will like he
definitely is a
he definitely kind of knows what he what
he what he wants to do so
i don't think so i i successfully
convinced him to to help me write the
next book of uh
of god the next series for god's dog
because we're we're working on like
another
another series which would be which will
be related to like legends of god's dog
and so he's agreed to do that but i
don't know how it's going to play out
because he's got he's got a lot of stuff
to deal with so
all right so christian clyde says hello
jonathan i'll try to reword my question
from last month okay all of the
disciples followed christ to the cross
saint john was the only disciple that
wasn't martyred in doing so not all of
them were crucified but martyrdom is its
own cross and icons of the crucifixion
we see saint john and the theotokos on
both sides from tradition we are told
that they both die naturally before
being bodily assumed into heaven i'm
wondering
if you have any insight there
i think you're i think there definitely
is an insight to have there there
definitely is something related to that
but i'm not sure what it is like i'm not
totally sure
what it means
yeah i'd have to think about it because
i i like why is it that the the that
saint john who was the closest
to christ right the one that laid on his
on his heart would
be the only one that wasn't martyred
when christ
himself was martyred
i don't know
if you think about that
there's definitely something there
all right so heroes ask why does
pinocchio's nose grow when he lies how
does this relate to what you said about
saints being depicted with long noses
and the idea that noses are associated
with finding truth
nosing around sniffing out uh
yeah there's the idea like the idea that
god has a long nose right it has to do
with something with like patience and
long suffering
but
i've never thought about why pinocchio's
nose grows like when he lies like
because the the the no the top of the
is the top of the
of the face right if you think of the
face like that then it's the highest
point of the face
and so why would it grow when you lie
um
i don't know
i don't know
i'm sure the guy who wrote pinocchio had
something in mind like what they had
something
in mind with that
but i have never thought about that so i
i i have no idea i mean it definitely
has something to do with
it i mean obviously that's something to
do with like his incapacity to hide
that he's lying like that's what it is
it's like so he lies and then he shows
it's like
you lie and then the signs appear of
your lying so for sure it has to do with
that but why the nose rather than
something else like why
why and it also has to do with the fact
that he's made of wood
um you know although that doesn't tell
you the meaning but it's clearly like
structurally that's what it's this is
what it seems like he was trying to go
for
all right so nick
eigensperger asks hi jonathan in rural
germany we have this folktale
of the
veter ganger sorry if i don't pronounce
that right video ganger is essentially
the spirit of a deceased person which
haunts people close to them often their
relatives now one of the ways a video
ganger can attach itself to person is
through them looking in the corpse's
eyes
i believe that this is definitely
related to the evil eye and vampires
however i would like to hear your
interpretation
and perspective on this um
so oh evan engel
says pinocchio's nose is a sign of pride
yeah that's a great that's probably
right you're probably right that that's
what it is
because the nose is the highest point on
the face and so
it has to do with
with with pride
so
probably right i'm not it's like i'm not
a hundred percent but i think that
that's definitely good
a good uh
a good possibility yvonne so thanks
all right so vader gangur
so the superstition is that if you look
in a person's
a dead person's eyes and you can be
haunted
you know by their ghosts let's say
um and so i mean it's not surprising as
a pattern it's like the idea
the idea would be to like to be cautious
with a with a dead person
that you don't
how can i say this it's like you don't
want to try to
see consciousness
in a dead person and so that seems to be
what's going on here it's like saying
i mean you could you could totally
explain this in a totally materialist
way like this you wouldn't have to
you know a complete material that's
gonna probably understand this pretty
simply it's like
why are you looking in the dead person's
eyes the person is dead so if you look
into their eyes into a dead person's
eyes it means you're trying
to see
soul like you're trying to see
life trying to see meaning in their eyes
and so
like surprise surprise
you might find some like you might but
it'll be a twisted like virgin that it's
going to wake you up at night you know
it's going to be something which is
going to haunt you
because
because death has certain
characteristics
that you know it has a certain eeriness
it has a certain it has a certain
uncanniness about it to look in per at a
person's dead face and to try to find
meaning that it's like that's probably
what a ghost is you know a ghost is
probably something like that it's like
the remainder of meaning
that a person leaves and if you try to
look for it like if you're trying to
even like trying to engage with it
trying to find it then it'll find you
you know and then
you might yeah you might have nightmares
after that
so
anyway that's the best way i understand
that
uh so charles harrow says what is the
symbolic significance of wedding rings
going on the left hand instead of the
right
they're different traditions by the way
like there are some traditions that have
that have them on the right hand
so but i think that
i think that in the that in the this
tradition has mostly to do with like the
the left hand as being something like
the the hand of protection or the hand
of of out right and so
you
like if you hold if you held a shield
you'd hold it with your left hand uh
it's also not the hand you do things
with and so
there's less chance that it'll get
caught in things but that has to do with
that as well right it has to do with the
fact that your left hand would be used
for a shield and your right hand would
be used to fight so it's like a hand
that is that is more clumsier but could
be used for defense and i think that
probably there's a practical reason
which is has to do with the fact that
the left hand is not something used for
work but there's also like that brings
about a symbolic reason which is
this idea of the hand of defense or the
hand of of pushing away
you know
uh that which is unwanted and so it's
like hey i'm married stay away it's like
you're married your husband knows you're
married the wedding ring in a way is
there to kind of remind you but it's
also to make other let other people know
that that that person is married so it's
like it's kind of like the hand that
pushes away you know
the left hand that pushes away
that that's the best i can do but i know
there's some there's some cultures where
it's actually on the right hand so maybe
there could be variations on that in
terms of what it means
all right so gogo says in the eastern
yogic concept of the kundalini energy
rising in the body
the same as the holy spirit is the
eastern yog conception of the kundalini
energy rising in the body the same as
the holy spirit
why is blasphemy against the holy spirit
the one forgivable sin
so
that's two questions goku
and uh
i'm gonna answer quick i don't think so
for the first one but i'm also not an
expert on kundalini yoga like i don't
really know much about it it's not a
there's something about it which which
kind of uh
there's something about it or something
about the obsession with it or there's
something about the type of people that
i've known
that have talked to me about it so much
uh that makes me suspicious of it
but you know i don't know i don't know
much about it but i can answer the
second one more easily i mean why is the
blasphemy against the holy spirit that
one unforgivable sin
i mean it has to do with the fact that
you're you're basically blaspheming
against the thing that's making you live
like the thing that makes you exist and
so
that's what it is but you know i don't
think
you know it's a it's if you treat
the the very spirit of god which let's
say
makes you exist
then
the spirit that was floating above the
waters like if you
if you misuse that then
yeah but i don't know i don't even know
like i don't totally understand
what that would be in your life like
what would it mean to blaspheme against
the holy spirit in a way that is
unforgivable
a lot of people debate about that and a
lot of people get caught up by that
and become nervous about it but
so sean desmond says symbolism of
tornadoes and wedding tornadoes feel
like such a uniquely american phenomenon
even though they have it everywhere it's
probably because you live in america
that's probably why you feel like they
are a uniquely
american phenomena
i mean they're the symbols of the
whirlwind like they're the symbolism of
of
you know an invisible force that is just
turning on itself and therefore is
destructive
that's the best i could do with that you
know it's not it's it's unfruitful wind
so
yeah
brad says where's your ring johnny it's
a good question it's actually it's
actually a funny question it's funny in
the sense that
uh
one day
once my
my wife lost her ring
and then she lost her ring
in a way that
she she let my child play with it
and then because of that she lost the
ring
and so
i
let her use my ring
and so she was using my ring and then
and then i think i think something
happened to that as well like i think it
was lost in some some moment and so we
just lost the rings and so we keep
telling ourselves like my wife and i
keep telling ourselves we're going to
make new wedding dreams we're going to
design them like they'll be really nice
and like an image of our relationship
and then
life goes on and things continue
we just don't do it and so but don't
worry i am very much married and have
been married uh for a very long time so
all right
so ajafka asks why are mostly male
animals sacrificed to god in the old
testament
yeah
that's weird i've never thought about
that it probably has to do with uh
it probably has something to do with
with
the idea of seed or the idea of
of the identity let's say the idea that
the man is the seed let's say probably
has something to do with that
but um
i haven't thought about it
so matthew muldenbrand says the lost
ring hobbits to the rescue that's
hilarious
um
so ivy asks hello i was wondering if the
proper hierarchy pattern that you have
described connected to the rich having
an obligation to let their blessings
flow down through them to the poor is
connected to the story of cain and abel
in some way
rich abel seemingly is not paying enough
any attention to cain who was poor
despite all of his efforts
they're not in proper communion am i
confused regarding this
is the wrong way of reading the story um
yeah i would say i would say it's
probably it's the wrong way to read the
story i don't see
where you get that
in the story like why does it why does
it seem like abel is rich
and not
attempt paying attention to cain who's
poor so i don't see that in the story it
doesn't say that it just says that
abel
sacrifices to god and his sacrifice is
accepted
and cain sacrificed to god it's not
accepted but he's bitter
and he's angry and so that's all it says
in the story so i mean i i understand
why for example jordan
jordan peterson sometimes extrapolates
on it and then creates this story about
the idea that everything's going well
for abel like he's good-looking that
it's not there in the story
i think that's just a way to help you
understand the idea that
that we have to understand that that
sometimes when we sacrifice our
sacrifices aren't accepted and we just
have to accept that but it doesn't i
don't think it implies
what you're suggesting so
all right so emmanuel montiel says hi
jonathan i can't help but feel like the
rainbow as a symbol of pride is a sort
of inversion of what the sciento really
stood for especially when considering
how babel is a story that immediately
follows the flood
is the pride month symbol of this
rainbow a sort of symbolism happens
moment
when are there and the constant
additions to the flag the sort of tower
babel in the making
so
no it's not a tower of babel you have to
understand the difference the tower of
babel is about unity the tower battle is
about one language the tablet was like
one thing
it's about gathering everybody into one
thing
whereas
the the the
the rainbow symbolism is about fluidity
and multiplicity and about
you know indefinite identity and so
it's a bridge like there's a positive
aspect to the rainbow symbolism that's
why god
uses it as a sign of a bridge between
heaven and earth
in in the
at the end of the flood
uh
but it's
in the way that it's used now it's
definitely a symbolism happens moment
because it's it is just this
this
an image of the lack of
of
of transparent light like the lack of
of pure light
and it's only refracted light
without the pure light and so
and then you just keep adding them
because
because of because the rainbow is is
fluid it's a indefinite amount of things
and so there's no limit to how many
things can be added at some point like
yeah
all right
gold it so maybe there's a funny like
right hesitate to say it so maybe at
some point they'll add so many like
gradations
into
the the
the flag and then they'll spin it and
then it'll just become white like it'll
just turn white like you do when you
spin like a rainbow
so i don't know anyways all right so
golden maybe that'll be like the final
flip or something like that
so golden pigeon of valor says once you
said that the symbolism and the narnia
series doesn't work why do you think so
no i didn't i'm not saying the symbolism
in the nardin books doesn't work i'm
saying that it's that i think that i
think that it is
not as
powerful as it could be because i think
that
there are a few things one is i think
i think that c.s lewis unlike tolkien
for example doesn't take into account
the quality of the beings that he places
in his narnia and so for example like a
satter
a fawn
you know has a certain characteristic
you know it's a it's a human with animal
legs and that usually those are related
to to sexual desire they're related to
you know centaurs are usually related to
aggressive
you know out of control sexual desire
and so to have them just be like
characters in the book like okay here's
the centaur here's the fawn here's all
these creatures and they don't have the
qualities of their
they don't have the qualities of what
they are i think that's the problem one
of the problems with the narnia book
um and so i so there are wonderful
things in the narnia book they're really
wonderful things but i think that he
kind of missed that whereas in in lord
of the rings right you have
like the orcs look like what they are
and the you know and the dwarves look
and manifest certain characteristics
and so all the different groups have
like characteristics about what they're
manifesting exteriorly and i think that
that's closer to what you find in
mythology you know
and so
and so yeah so so i think that that's
the issue
one of the issues let's
say all right so ken
lowry asks i recently had a conversation
with john viveki working through aspects
of bridging christianity to his work i'm
formulating thoughts on the primary
question he asked me and love to hear
you
address it as well his question relates
to the deity of christ in so far as
christ's final words my god my god why
have you forsaken me
i'm not interested in parroting your
thoughts rather i'm interested in how
you would frame this and pitfalls you
might avoid
and so i think that
the best way to understand that
is to understand
father john uh father john father
stephen young
he talked about it in one of the the
podcast i forget where it was
but
it has to do with something like
a lot of the other stuff that's going on
with christ right and so a lot of the
other stuff that go is going on with
christ is that on the surface it looks
like something but it's hiding a deep
deep irony which is which is hidden
underneath and so when christ is being
beaten and and uh
you know in being mocked for being a
king it's actually revealing his
kingship so as he is as he's emptying
himself
you know he is also becoming full at the
same time
and so this is what christ is doing on
the cross so it's like as he's dying on
the cross then everybody's mock as a
criminal and as the the worst type of
person above his head is an ironic
statement about him being the king which
is actually true and so he's actually
filling up that role while he is
emptying at the same time it's a deeply
mystical
image
and this is what happens to christ all
through the crucifixion story so when
christ says my god my god why have you
forsaken me you have to understand what
that refers to that's a psalm
and it's a psalm that talks about that
uses an image of resurrection
at the end of that psalm and so this is
the
king david's call to god god oh god why
have you forsaken me and there's this
sense of being abandoned and emptying it
and an emptying of yourself
and then when the psalm ends there's a
fullness and a resurrection and so this
is what christ is really so i don't want
to diminish
the re the deep mystery of christ saying
that on the cross there's a very very
deep mystery
but it doesn't it does not at all
um
it does not at all deny his divinity it
is rather the deep
the deep kind of cohen
eporya moment
where in emptying himself he is also
revealing the the fullness
and and in saying that he is also and it
because it is a quote from a psalm and
read the psalm you'll see where the
psalm takes you and it's like it's like
hiding it's hidden in what he's saying
that what he's moving towards
the final glorification the final
restoration is coming and so that's what
i think
is happening you know so
i hope that answers that it's as good as
i can do
but i want like i want to say one last
thing i want to be careful that we don't
think
that this is just a game right that this
is just a play it's not like there's a
reality to what's happening when christ
is being tortured he's not like on the
inside going haha i got them i'm
actually the king and you know you know
like secretly knowing what is going on
like there's a reality to what is
happening and that reality is truly
christ is truly crying you know on the
on the mount of olives he's truly
sweating sweating blood
uh you know whatever that means it's
like he's truly in a moment of deep of
deep uh
but we
the way the whole story is told he's
showing how in that in that emptying he
is also reaching
totality and fullness and that quote is
is
is just part another one of those
versions and so i think that if someone
questions that
i think that showing them that this is
happening all through the story it's not
like one thing i'm not just trying to
avoid the problem it's like this is
what's happening all through the story
of the crucifixion uh and so this is
this is
is it's not an it's not a it's not an
exception it's actually following the
pattern so
so brandon byrd says is the descent of
the holy ghost at pentecost the
rectification of the confusion of
tongues during the construction of the
tower of babel and the answer is yes
it's actually sometimes called the
anti-babble and so it is it is in a way
a rectification of the confusion of
tongues like it's not a return to babel
it's not it's not a return to like
of complete like uh uniformity but it is
rather a transformation of the splitting
of the tongues that happened at babel
into something
something glorious that can participate
in the glory of god and so that's what's
interesting about about the the the
pentecost so you could almost see it
like in a way pentecost is continuing
what happened at babel but in a way that
transforms it into a kind of glory so
it's a it is a rectification that's
probably the best it is the best term to
use so
all right so
alexander says hi jonathan i hope you're
doing well i've been praying for you
well thank you alexander
my question is regards to history and
great men what is the symbolic tendency
of revolution in civil wars to culminate
into a single figure wielding absolute
power caesar cromwell nepali and stalin
yeah and why and in what way does christ
point towards how to break out of this
pattern thank you
i mean you're totally right that's what
it is like revolution leads to tyranny
there's no doubt about that there's no
doubt about that and it's a it's
something about a
there's something in the mechanism of
revolution which makes tierney almost
necessary
um you know because
as you break down as you let's assault
the order you know then you fall into
like all these chaotic competing
principalities
and then there'll be a competition or
there'll be a wit someone who'll seize
that chaos right well able to to re to
turn it back towards another purpose and
that will usually happen in the
tyrannical way uh and so how does christ
point towards the break out of this
pattern is that christ
rules his kingdom through self-sacrifice
so christ
doesn't so so i've i've said this before
it's like christ doesn't
cause a social revolution against the
roman empire
right so some people
at the time the zealots they expected
the messiah to come like a king
that would free them from the romans
that would fight off the romans and
would free israel
judah
from the romans and then christ doesn't
do that and so a lot of people say well
he's not the messiah right
and so that's the thing that's the
secret is that
christ
the pattern that christ
manifests is the notion of planting the
seed and of self-sacrifice
and it's a way to transform the world
without falling into just dialectic
and so what happens is that christ does
take over rome
it just takes longer it's all but it's
also more permanent
in the sense that christ takes over rome
a few centuries later
and it it lasts for
what
fifteen hundred years maybe uh you know
or
a thousand years at least a thousand
years it lasts so it's not bad you know
and so it's like and then it leads to
something like antichrist
uh but which is still part of the
pattern somehow like
so so that's the difference that's a
difference
all right and so dorothea says hi
jonathan i watch your video on the
symbolism of the far east and i guess
i'm spiritually asian
or something because i recognize myself
as a small version of that pattern i
even literally dreamt that god is
building a house for me
so my question is if you have some
advice how to put all of that in service
of god you mentioned the three magi
giving their gifts to the child jesus is
it connected to that
i'm not sure i understand you're why
does it why are you saying that you
dreamt that god is building a house for
you
is that something we talked about in the
symbolism of the far east did i miss
something i'm not sure i totally
understand your question tortilla i'm
sorry um
that you're spiritually asian because
you recognize yourself as a small
version of
that pattern you know oh you mean the
pattern of
let's say sending someone from the west
to build a house for the east and so the
east appears as like the seeds let's say
and then the west appears as the home or
the house so you right so it's like an
image of the of the temple or the
tabernacle itself right the tabernacle
has the ark of the covenant in the west
and then the glory of god comes down
from the east and then lands you know in
the west and so uh so that's also so you
could also imagine like you send
builders to the east to build a house
and so and so i i i understand um
so you mentioned the three magi giving
their gifts to the child jesus is it
connected to that and so
in a way it is it is
in the sense that the gifts that the
magi give christ is something like
gifts that recognize his divinity and so
they're sending
their
authority like or they're
they're doing they're pointing to christ
they're coming from the east with like
with insight and they're saying
that's the messiah right there and their
gifts are there to tell to like point to
the messiah and so they are acting like
light they're acting like rays of light
coming from the east that are pointing
to the mysterious uh like this
mysterious
hidden thing that is in the cave you
know
in the in more in the west
so yes definitely it's related to that
um but i don't know
i don't know what you mean by putting
that in the service of god
all right so kulai says what is the
symbolism of the morning star as in
spiked mace
called morning star
spiked mace i don't know what that is
the meaning of its form and the relation
to the aspergillum
i have no idea what you're talking about
i don't know what spiked mace is
and i don't know what aspergillum is
it's like oh it's a sprinkle holy water
see i didn't know that had a name
aspergillum
it's a good name to remember that
uh
it's related to the aspergillum
the meaning of of its form and the
relation to the spiritual
so i've never thought about any of that
i had never heard this relationship that
you're talking about
um so sorry
uh as for the idea of the meaning of the
morning star i mean it's the it has to
do with
with lucifer right that's the idea of
the morning star and so
and so you can
you can understand lucifer in several
ways and i think it's pretty probably
good maybe i mentioned this before in a
q a
people have to stop freaking out about
the term lucifer like i understand that
in some circles and in some ways it's
interpreted as being
satan but
you know christ is called lucifer in
scripture christ is called the morning
star in scripture
and it means the light bearer right the
one that bears the light
and so
the reason why the devil or the evil one
is has come to take the name lucifer is
that it's the idea that
the morning star appears in the in the
sky
and it it's like what it does is it's
it's like basically bring it's like
calling to the sun right it's like it's
it's basically preceding the sun and so
you can understand that
so saint john the baptist for example in
liturgical attacks is called also the
morning star and and there are many
other
people that are called the morning star
because they're they're the forerunner
right so like saint john the baptist is
lucifer because he's the foreigner to
christ he is the morning star that comes
up and then
and then the sun follows so you and so
the reason why christ is called that is
because you could say that he is the the
image bearer of the father right and so
it's just a structural relationship of
the the morning star that comes up and
then you know that the sun is coming
later so it's like it it's like uh it's
like uh
comes out before the the the sun and so
so the reason why the evil one is called
lucifer is that you can imagine that the
morning star thinks that it's got it
like the morning star thinks that it's
the one it's like i am the light right i
look at me i'm so bright and i'm and i'm
the light and so it fills itself up with
pride so because of that it falls
because it it gets completely flooded
out by the light of the sun it just
vanishes when the sun comes up comes out
and so that's why that term or the idea
of the morning star is used
in different guises in time in terms of
symbolic thinking uh so you have to be
cautious because you know i've seen
people
let's say play like masses for example
um
where in the mass it's it's actually
seeing the verse where christ is called
lucifer and it's and then people like
you know think it's like some secret
thing that like the catholic church is
worshiping the devil you know and so
people just get nuts like they just
don't understand this stuff so uh so
yeah
so
yeah all right so there you go that's as
much as i'm gonna say about that but the
aspergillum
someone says the aspergillum is
a weapon
so this learning star is a bludgeon
well it kind of looks like one i'm
seeing i'm looking at it here and i can
see that it does actually kind of look
like a bludgeon so maybe maybe in some
cases it is
all right
all right enough on the aspergillum
all right so norm grenade says what is
symbolic significance of the fruit that
adam and eve eat being an apple
scripture never identified the fruit of
such but it seems universally understood
to be an apple
i don't think so i think it really
depends on the culture like there really
are really many fruits that have been um
that have
been had the the have been called the
fruit but i think more recently or like
in the last few hundred years
the apple for some reason
has become an image of the of the fruit
but it's not that it's not that old of a
of an interpretation um
and so
i mean i think that
like there's like there's like the
simple version like the kind of
superstitious version which is
interesting which is that an apple kind
of looks like two halves like you kind
of see the two halves in the apple right
it's it's like a heart kind of and then
you know if you
so i think that there's probably
something to do with that something the
fact that it's common too it's a common
fruit in europe and in the west
something that everybody knows what it
is
so it might be that as well
um
yeah
not sure
so arie fisher says hi jonathan i've
been learning a bit more about the logoy
recently and how they are in maximus's
act theology actually uncreated
yeah and basically divine energies of
god timothy teaches to describe them as
the way in which christ empties himself
for the life of the world i'm wondering
though what is the distinction between
the low gi or the low guy and angels as
you describe them i'm wondering if the
two don't get conflated in the way you
describe angels
i was thinking that the angels were the
points of unity above the multiplicity
of phenomena but the angels are created
and are not the logoe are they like the
next thing down from the logo forgive me
for dragging you into technical
metaphysics it's not all clear in my
mind
yeah i mean i think that's probably the
way to understand that you know in the
sense that the angels are they're the
they're they're invisible
patterns that can be
grasped right or seen that can have
influence you know but they also
definitely have a logoy and you could
probably understand the logi
switching the way i say it but you could
already understand the logi as
they're akin to that because they the
logi also seems to kind of exist in this
hierarchy of purposes
of hidden purposes that that are joined
into into god but they're definitely you
know when we talk about theosis like
we're serious about theosis you know the
idea that that your
that
your origin
you know that the highest part of you is
god
like it's actually the it's actually the
divine energy like that's the highest
part of you and so
lisa parrott says maybe the apple you
know the apple because of apple like
apple computers
well for sure apple computers is
definitely
playing on that like they're definitely
saying that they are eating the apple of
the garden that is for sure
but i think the apple came before apple
computers like
so greg garcia says hi jonathan how did
the ancients approach history that is in
contrast to a modern historical critical
method polish stats
pole statistics motives whether
political economic or social everyone is
fighting over the narrative of history
would people have done this in antiquity
if they had the technology the hyper
focus on
ironically on it ironically seems to be
breaking down trust
so i think that
ancients approach history the way that
we talk about universal history in the
in our universal history series so if
you're interested in that you can watch
those
videos you can get a sense of of
the more mythical origin
of historical action and the idea of
finding common story like that is
actually what makes history and so the
fact that right now everybody's arguing
about
common story whether it be
you know the kind of multiplication of
historical narratives of the past you
know whether it be these these different
like uh
reinterpretations of of american history
or canadian history
and
is how it has to do with reaching the
end you know because you can understand
it like in a positive or negative way
give me a second i just need to open my
door
sorry sometimes i run out of air
in my in my little office so i made it
sound proof but it turns out i also made
it air proof because i made it sound
proof
um
and so so think about it like um
think about in two ways so think about
it in the negative sense so in the sense
that so you have a common identity in a
common history and a common
core that binds you together
and so now there are now when you reach
the end of that when it's running out of
steam what happens that all these
elements they want to
rev they want to capture the story and
so one aspect of the history is like
wants to capture it so what it does is
it fragments because you have a you
start to have fighting everybody's
fighting over the story like what's the
story and that is what it shows is that
the story is breaking down and so now
there is this infighting about who's
going to control identity and story so
you can see it that way but you could
also see it
in a sympathetic way towards
these stories these these multiple
stories which is that
in order to create a myth or a story you
have to order things in a certain way
and to do that you also have to you have
to exclude and marginalize certain
aspects
of society because we're not god we
don't encompass all things and so in
doing that you are it's like you're
casting out or you're casting down
certain elements of interaction you are
casting roles on certain elements of the
of the of the story and some of those
are not great like some of those are not
are not particularly
pleasant or some people are in a way do
become like the victim of that story
because they end up in a marginal spot
and so when you reach the end it's like
so when this story now starts to run out
of steam
you can also have sympathy for the all
these competing stories now that want to
free themselves from
the negative aspect of the
of the story
right so
um
right so think about so think about it
like imagine i'm trying to find some
some some version it's like imagine a
society where in that society there
is a lower caste in that society and
that lower caste is blamed for
everything that lower caste is blamed
for all the problems all the stupidity
and so they they they're constantly the
butt of the jokes are constantly the
ones that are are you know become the
scapegoat for all the behavior and so
that works like it holds the world
together you have a coherent story you
have a scapegoat you just put all your
bad stuff in there and then it like
functions but then when you reach the
end of that story it's like that
scapegoat is still there
and it's gonna come back
why wouldn't it come back
you know it's gonna return and it's
gonna return with a scythe like it's
gonna return with vengeance so
it's like that's also one of the things
that's going on in in the story right
now
um
and it's like i'm not even saying one is
good or the other is bad or like i'm not
trying to
i'm not trying to say that
that this should happen i'm just saying
it is happening and i and and we have to
be able to understand it and be able to
see it from all sides because i don't
particularly like
watching the narrative get
completely corrupted and that there's
these parasitic narratives that try to
take over the the the story but i also
kind of i understand why it's happening
you know i get it so uh
yeah so
yeah that's it
all right so
and so yeah and so but i mean i think
that there are excesses and so it'll
become
the revenge of the scapegoat
it's not neces it's not good
right it's excessive and it'll you know
it'll create its own scapegoats and
it'll create its own kind of
weird narrative so i'm not saying that
i'm not trying to justify anything i'm
just trying to help you hopefully
understand
what is going on and what is happening
right
now
all right so russ fro asked could you
comment of the depictions of snails
often found in the marginalia of
medieval manuscripts
yeah i mean
i don't know what do you want to
understand it's like it's a
a snail is a is is a clear like
inversion of
of a of of you you know because you have
hard stuff on the inside and soft stuff
on the outside
and so a snail has soft stuff on the
inside and hard stuff on the outside
and so that's it i don't know it's a
it's an upside down it's an upset it's a
bug first of all it's also a bug and
it's also you know it's a it's funny
looking
um
[Music]
but i think that it it it has to do with
that as well like slugs and snails
especially a snail because it has a it
has a
shell so
all right so william lawrence what is
the symbolism of coffee especially in a
church setting almost every church i've
been to offers coffee whether it's a
mini cafe in a mega church or it's
coffee hour after divine liturgy is this
just a convenience for modern adults or
the is there more going on here i mean
it's medicine right coffee's medicine
coffee is a is a stimulant so
it's like uh
it's like a jolt it's like it's like a
supplement that's what coffee is so
you know
that's probably why coffee's kind of
taken over
i drink coffee you know at least one a
day
so it's like it is definitely like a
stem and there's something rich there's
a ritual about coffee too
like you kind of have to make it it's
not it doesn't just come like you can't
just like buy a bottle like you buy a
bottle of water a bottle of coke or
whatever you have to have it has to be
made so there's something about that i
think which is also attractive to people
without maybe unconsciously like there's
a sense in which this there's still like
i have to prepare it right a little bit
and so there's a little ritual that goes
with coffee and you can see how people
become weirdly ritualized about their
coffee you know so
so abe says i john i think you speak
about the symbolism of owls on the one
hand the bible seems to portray them as
unclean birds and harbingers of ruin and
they've been associ they've been a
favorite of secret societies but on the
other hand they have a powerful
associated with knowledge and wisdom
from ancient greece even to modern area
do you see a way to reconcile their
symbolism with christianity
i mean sure you know
animals especially animals like they
definitely have multiple symbolism and
so the way that the symbolism will be
represented will be
contextual to the other elements and so
i think the idea of the wise out is
totally fine
as a story trope um
but you know i think also the idea of
the of the owl as like like important of
something of something dark is also
totally possible you could use both and
so
so i think that you can there's no
there's no absolutely nothing there's
nothing you don't have to reconcile the
symbolism with christianity they're
they're animals that exist in the world
and so i think they have depending on
their context they can
they can rep they can manifest uh
different aspects of what they are
so chandler trying to say jonathan i
must admit i was embarrassingly excited
to see you in conversation with bernardo
castro i've been reading his books and
following his work for a while now and i
got to see a different side of him in
your video bernardo's work is often
based around metaphysical idealism which
he didn't discuss in too much detail
during your talk so i was wondering what
your thoughts on the subject are and if
you had any broader reflection on the
conversations you had with them thanks
so i really avoided the idea
the question of idealism because i think
in a certain manner
i think it's like oh it's like a false
herring it's like a it's it's like a
it's like a it's there's something about
it that doesn't matter and so like when
you re when you notice like bernardo's
categories
and so he wants so he says like he
denies matter
so he sees
everything as as mind let's say
uh but he doesn't
deny the like the objective existence of
the things you find out there it doesn't
mean that everything is is is is a rel
is idiosyncratic everything functions
with a pattern and and it's like what we
recognize as
matter or objects they are they are
let's say
they are mentations you know but they
all have a structure and they have a
certain way of existing and so in a way
it was kind of like
i think that in a way i was i was like i
don't think that that matters because if
you could say like if you said something
if you said something
something like all things exist in the
mind of god
constantly all things are are constantly
existing in the mind of god that's a
completely christian thing to say like
there's absolutely nothing
weird about that
and that the idea that matter exists on
its own and has a completely independent
existence is something that christians
don't believe either like i hope not if
you believe that it's like matter
doesn't just exist right it is sustained
by god and in god and it and it and it
doesn't have stability
at the bottom
right it's held by loki and that's how
it finds its stability so it's stability
is held in their purposes and in their
higher things and so the fact that we
have
so so i think that like whether you use
the word mind or
it's like i don't think that that's
where the real debate is i think
i think it's more about understanding
the manner which is system works and how
how to
account for the fractality and the the
way that things fit into each other
you know into into the mind of god and
so i think that ultimately we probably
disagree
we didn't get to all the points of it
uh but i hope that and we're going to
have another discussion at some point so
i hope that in our next discussion we
can address some of those issues so
that's why so i think that the question
of so
so i think that the question of idealism
and
uh let's say
at least in his case
it doesn't you really have to just look
at the system itself and stop
worrying about about
about what would it how can i say this
of thinking that it
because the category he has all the
categories even though he thinks that
they're bound that they're held in mind
let's say so he does have something like
wood or table or
or but they are held by
by mentations by mental processes that's
how they kind of are held together in
our perception and in the world and so
so when he says something like matter
doesn't exist i think i think it's it's
this how can i say it it's like it's
kind of a scandalous statement
and i understand why people react to it
but if you actually look at his system
he doesn't just mean that nothing exists
that's not what he means uh
and so so that's why i didn't want to go
into that with him i just i wanted to go
into the nitty-gritty of the actual way
in which all these things fit together
and i was really surprised i was happily
surprised to see that there was that if
i did it that way
that there was a lot more
points of
that where we touched our ideas touch
and where we could find some kind of uh
some connection than if i had started to
to argue about idealism itself so
hopefully that makes sense
so daniel asks i spent some time with an
atheist friend this week
who i had not seen since becoming
orthodox he was curious about my
conversion but i feel as though we were
talking past each other he kept speaking
to me as if i was a fundamentalist yeah
that's going to happen i feel as though
i didn't do a good job of explaining the
orthodox understanding of god my friend
even went as far as to say that thoughts
aren't real
whatever
how do you explain this sort of stuff to
materialists and people who are so
invested in science and
empiricism yeah i mean you've got a long
road ahead of you i don't know what to
tell you i mean
i think there are tools right now and so
i think i mean obviously that's what i'm
trying to do
um
[Music]
so i'm sure you might be able to find
tool kits in the things that i talk
about which is
right and so the idea of science and
empiricism
when we talk when john vivek and i talk
about something like combinatorial
explosion
the problem of multiplicity in unity and
so it's like if you can bring someone
into that space where they're thinking
about that like the fact that things
exist both as
all things exist both as multiples and
unities at the same time that they seem
to have parts and have unity together
that i think i think that if you can
start to get them into that space
then at some point they'll start to to
understand that they're
like the the saying that thoughts aren't
real is just the dumbest i mean it's
such a dumb statement it's like
but sorry i don't want to insult your
friend or anything but
but you have to you i think bringing
them into that space like of
understanding the necessity of
consciousness and all that it may be a
way to kind of approach it but
but uh but i know the feeling man i know
the feeling and i also know like the
kind of contempt or that look in the eye
of your atheist friend that thinks
you're some kind of an idiot
and then them not knowing not
understanding what you're talking about
at the same time
i know that feeling you really you
really gotta you gotta you gotta hold on
to that right you gotta grab on to that
and take it as like joy you really have
to every time
some like materialist atheist looks at
you and looks at you like you're a
ten-year-old and you're a superstitious
idiot and and you know you're uh
you you just gotta smile and you just
gotta you gotta really take it as joy
because that's really the best way to do
it or else or else it's unbearable you
know
uh
you you okay so
explaining it what do i mean you have to
take it as really as something like
in this case like with with this with
the person like that you have to take it
like
i have a secret understanding like i
have a secret understanding that this
person standing in front of me
i have like it's like i i have this
giant treasure the secret treasure this
person like can't see it they can't see
it
and so it's like that's what i mean but
you have to find joy in it
because
especially if you worked it out
especially if you know that these things
are like a lot of these questions and
and and and uh discussions are bring
about the inevitability of
of of in invisible patterns right it's
like
you know so you just so you just gotta
you just gotta take that as joy like
yeah i've got this beautiful treasure
and you can't see it i'm sorry man sorry
for you bro that's all you could do
all right
all right so jason schweitzer asks when
a word is continually used it seems to
lose its elasticity and poetic nature
and resolve into a type of prose
what does
does this happen with icons throughout
the process of time
and and overuse of the icon does it
settle into an idol and then history
needs to needs the iconoclasm
the crushing seduce of the idol that the
original thought
once found and the icon may again be set
free to find a new yet similar similar
form
um
[Music]
you mean like icons in the church like
is that what you mean or
or do you just mean images if you mean
icons in the church i mean
i could i mean i guess i could ask you
the same like does the bible become an
idol
like the icons of the church
you know the the types of the icons of
the church have been really worked out
theologically very profoundly and so
so i can imagine that like let's say you
can imagine that for example like a
physical version of the bible
you know like an actual physical version
of the bible like someone could come to
treat it like an idol like that could be
possible so you could maybe imagine
like an actual physical uh icon that
people
excessively
you know
treat as if it's god itself or something
like that like i mean i think that may
be possible
but but not the like not
not the bible like right and not the
icons that is not the type not the
pattern that that that makes the
particular ones exist
i don't think that that can become
yeah i don't think that can become an
idol maybe i don't know like if people
get too caught up with like thinking
that the bible is god itself which i see
maybe it's possible yeah maybe
um
all right
all right guys
so
we're done look at that
9 30. we didn't get to 10. so that's
probably good you know we we always go
go sometimes too long with these
and so uh so yeah so thanks everybody
for showing up thanks thanks for uh
thanks for for coming along and uh and
uh we'll see you we'll see you next
month
and uh thanks everybody bye bye
you